würden sie es heute ganz klar sagen ja
der söder auch für die cdu das kann mal
richtig gut vorstellen
na klar kann man sich das vorstellen vor
allem wenn man weiß das finde ich
wichtig dass derzeit zwei menschen gibt
in der bundesrepublik sage ich als
staatsbürger die krise können angela
merkel und markus söder und das ist
schon mal wichtig weil das auch
vertrauen schafft ich möchte jetzt keine
leute an der spitze haben in einem
bundesland oder auch eine
bundesregierung die bei dieser krise
gescheitert werden wer weiß wie das land
hin gestört werden wie wir gesehen haben
sind die sind eh in ihren augen ja
vielleicht nicht gescheitert da haben
wir nicht bewährt also sparen lasse
natürlich die dazu diene exekutive
zunächst sehen wir lassen jetzt sparen
ganz besonders norbert röttgen und
friedrich merz haben wir keine exekutive
funktionen können dass ich auch nicht so
stattfinden
aber entscheidend ist doch dass die
beiden angela merkel und markus söder
auch an der spitze stehen bei den
beliebtheitswerten das sind immer
momentaufnahmen ist ja nicht ganz
unwichtig dass die leute zunächst
vertrauen in die handelnden personen
haben bei markus söder gibt es spitzen
werden bayern von über 90 prozent die
hat fast nie in amtierender
ministerpräsident hat er sicher arbeiten
letzten monat ist eine ganz wichtige
voraussetzung